in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatments alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape helping patients
with an anxiety disorder is the area of
expertise of my guests in this studio
today psychiatrist dr. bhavan Bandello
thank you very much for joining us hello
dr. van Lowe there are different forms
of anxiety disorders but they've all got
one thing in common the patients suffer
fear that's grown completely out of
proportion why does that happen why do
we experience such fear sometimes well
fear and anxiety are quite normal
feelings and we need them to survive but
there's a high overlap between normal
anxiety and pathological anxiety in many
patients we have this pathological
anxiety when the fear is completely out
of proportion and why does it develop to
be that way you know well the origin of
anxiety disorders is multifactorial that
means we have your biological causes you
might have environmental factors like
emotional stress in the youth or in the
last weeks before i get an anxiety
disorder but also we have some genetic
reasons that means about fifty percent
of the anxiety disorders are inherited
mm-hmm so there are some physical
components that's not just a mere
psychological disease all right well
let's speak about the different forms of
anxiety disorders that there are many
people have heard about phobias when
you're you're scared of something
specific like spiders for example how
does that happen why do we develop a
phobia suddenly well in spite of phobias
go back to a 20 100 thousand years
before when it was when it did make
sense to have spider phobia otherwise
you would have been killed by a spider
but today in many countries there spider
phobia is unnecessary
but we still have it in our genes the
spider phobia okay so that's the sort of
disorder way where your fear is
triggered by something specific but then
there are other forms where the fear
comes out of the blue can you explain to
us what happens there well many patients
suffer from panic attacks that means
they just go on a pedestrian mall or in
a crowded place and then they suddenly
have this anxiety attack with a pounding
heart and they have dyspnea they have a
choking feeling and the fear of dying
and that just occurs out of the blue for
no particular reason yes and some
patients occurs out of the blue but in
others it occurs in special situations
when they fear that they might need a
doctor for this condition but they it's
difficult to find a doctor like if
you're in a soccer stadium then you
think it's maybe dangerous because the
doctor cannot come to you but you don't
need a doctor in this situation because
it goes away but the patients do not
know that oh so when they feel that they
can't get help then they get scared sort
of thing right here and why you know why
would someone develop such a panic or
such such a lightness to do have a panic
attack well you must have some Center in
the brain that has a unrealistic
reaction without any course it just
causes the this this emergency
fight-or-flight reaction which is
unrealistic in the moment because
there's no danger around so it's a
neurological thing yes well um how can
you help someone who might be prone to
suffering from anxiety disorders like
that well we have a friend or family
member I mean sorry yes and we have as a
friend of the family you should notice
that it's not go to let the patient
avoid things it's better to tell the
patient to expose himself to all these
feared situations at any time instead of
avoiding them and
as a relative sometimes you might think
it's better for him if you take care of
him and leave him at house alone but
this is not not good it's better to tell
him to not to avoid these things dr.
banlieue you work in a clinic with
patients that suffer from anxiety
disorders from that experience what are
the most effective forms of treatment so
we have cognitive behavior therapy and
then we have the drugs and first the
behavior therapy includes exposure to
feared situations that means if you are
afraid of dogs you have to work with
dogs if you're afraid of pedestrian
malls you have to go out there and this
is very important just to talk about
fear is not so effective and on the
other side we have the drugs usually we
take drugs that do not have these severe
side effects like addiction and we they
do not change the personality and they
do not have like sedating effects which
would exclude car driving or anything
else Oh interesting that answers the
questions that many of our viewers had
like Maria Rosa from Sheila she asked if
you know medication prescribed for
anxiety disorders might change her
personality but that's definitely not
the case you not the case all right well
let's speak about the exposure therapy
you know to expose someone who's scared
of spiders to spiders that can be quite
an ordeal for the patient how exactly
does that help them well in the first
moment you're very scared to take a
spider on your hand but in the next
moment when it's already on the hand
then you suddenly have the feeling it's
not as bad as I thought and when you
repeat this a lot of times and you can
take any spider on your hand even like
weird spiders in that and many dangerous
species so you sort of learn that the
fear won't kill you and and if you are
the the trigger off your fear won't
Killian won't harm you and then that
repetition gets yes you have a very
primitive Center in your brain which
wants you of spiders but then you have
to convince this
primitive center by doing something not
just talking about because this doesn't
listen to you if you just talk about it
you have to do this this is very
important teach your brain that spiders
aren't really that dangerous um how can
you can you actually cure anxiety
disorders yes we can make it much better
than most people people with anxiety
disorders can just live like normal
people after like a couple of weeks of
treatment usually they go back to normal
and can just live their own lives
alright well that's a promising outlook
well thank you very much for being our
guest today thanks for your time dr.
bundle oh
you